you see that twenty five hundred dollars
11 inches of LED fury a million-to-one
contrast ratio Sony's new organic
light-emitting diode television it's the
first of this technology to market but
it will not be the last it's three
millimeters thick it's super bright it's
got a million to one contrast ratio
that's like a thousand times brighter
than anything else and its twenty five
hundred dollars for that but it's the
ultimate CEO desk accessory it's tech
status and it's totally lust-worthy
peekaboo look at the panasonic HDC sc9
it's so tiny it's the world's smallest
through HD camcorder it's 1080p and it's
smaller than a squirrel's brain it's 800
bucks and you can get about five and a
half hours on the largest SD card which
is 32 gigabytes any less not you get
less content but it's 1080p so it's
gonna take full advantage of your brand
new flat screen only a year ago a
wrist-mounted GPS was like having a
graphic calculator strapped to your arm
but now garmin has come out with the new
4runner which is the size of a regular
watch in fact it's actually little
smaller than the watch that I wear every
day it's got a full GPS receiver in it
tracks you when you're running and even
let you run against virtual partners you
can then download your course to your
computer and see where you went see how
many miles you ran what your elevation
changes were like what your speed was
like and you can race yourself the next
day
you